[Musique]
alors ça y est nous sommes déloger c'est
comme ça que vous laisser s'installer
maxime saury et sont hors caisse dans
notre cuisine
oui c'était parce qu'ils étaient en
train de s'installer justement oui on
annonce et parce que les hommes sont
toujours en retard contrairement à ce
qu'on dit c'est pour ça que l'émission
commence avec un peu de retard
première d'une nouvelle série la cuisine
pour les hommes
pourquoi la cuisine pour les arts est
bien parce que je pense que les hommes
sont un peu déshérités dans la vie vous
savez en leur donnant beaucoup de choses
à faire quelquefois parce que ils ne
font pas la cuisine que pour s'amuser il
ya des moments où il faut la cuisine
aussi pour rendre service à leurs femmes
ce qui arrive même assez fréquemment
et alors je voudrais que lorsque la
femme a laissé un tout petit morceau de
papier en disant fais cuire les sols
pour les enfants elle va te les trouvera
dans le réfrigérateur
il faut tout de même qu'ils sachent
comment il faut faire cuire ses sols
parce que cuir des sols c'est quand même
un problème alors je voudrais aider ces
sommes très décidés désirer j'essayais
tout à l'heure eh bien je voudrais
essayer les étés je voudrais et c'est
d'essayer de les aider en leur
expliquant comment se font les choses
les plus simples et plus petits tops si
vous allez faire de la cuisine c'est
extrêmement ce vous allez transformer
sans enjeu voilà je voudrais que ça
devienne un tout petit grant kippen
un petit peu un jeu de construction vous
avez qui se compliquent petit à petit on
ajoute des pièces grâce à wii alors
après ça on ajoute une goutte de cognac
on enlève un d eux que l'on remplacé par
auto shop boys la rage comme on n'a pas
envie qui est que vous qui vous aviez
cette émission va faire l'objet d'un
concours
ce concours c'est un grand jeu auquel
sont invités à participer tous nos
téléspectateurs voilà il faudra que pour
chaque émission de cuisine pour les
hommes vous soyez extrêmement attentifs
que vous n'étiez bien tout ce que
raymond l'hiver essaiera de vous montrer
ces roms et que pour ma part je tenterai
de vous rendre un peu plus clair lorsque
tout de même ça me paraîtrait vous ferez
quelques photographies ou si vous n'avez
pas d'appareils photographiques gouffre
et des dessins vous mettrez des légendes
plus nourris stick possible n'est ce pas
nous faisons appel à votre esprit à
votre
audition enfin tout ce qu'il faut toute
façon on en reparlera tout à l'heure de
ce concours
mais croyez moi il va commencer à la
prochaine mission celle d'aujourd'hui
n'est pas valable pour ne pas content
d'ailleurs elle ne compte pour rien
d'ailleurs même pas l'âge où d'hubert
faune hubert bon alors à ce propos nous
allons nous rendre là bas
j'espère que mes biens et si vous voulez
elle voulait lier alors là c'est
énormément ils ont fait beaucoup de
bruit qui n'ont rien caché est donc
assez bon laisser la musique
vous avez vu comment il savait s'en
servir lui maxime saury de votre heure
oui oui c'est vrai c'est vrai j'ai alors
voyez je crois comme ça ça soit
l'indicatif d'ailleurs nous l'avons dire
qu'on l'indicatif de l'émission la
colline pour les hommes pour faire une
différence
alors voilà j'ai pris une pour les
hommes aujourd'hui oui vous savez les
hommes aiment qui est du matériel
il progresse à en faire des cuisines
comme ça avec un couteau et une
fourchette et une assiette
non il faut du matériel alors il adore
les gadgets aussi alors oui ça les
gadgets c'est très important aussi
maintenant ça c'est la fleur évidemment
qu'on aurochs en réserve on dirait sa
dépouille
elle épousa l'aimé alors aujourd'hui ce
sont les élèves de l'école
d'alimentation de la ville de paris et
qu'ils ont fait c'est drôle car est en
sucre elle a été faite pour vous alors
passé et les petits cadres lui-même est
fabriquée par les celliers de l'école de
céleri de la ville de paris également
pour ça ils s'aiment bien gentil tout
danger de la crise signé par six ans non
pas du tout
alors on pourrait commencer à travailler
où l'on voyait il s'agit de faire un
plat comme les hommes en effet en effet
les hommes aiment fait un certain genre
de plat et aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas
du tout d'une recette culinaire c'est il
s'agit d'illustrer comme les
téléspectateurs et ses rondes illustré e
l'émission nous allons essayer
d'illustrer si je peux dire les
téléspectateurs que le cuisinier alors
pas du tout professionnelle d'ailleurs
mais uniquement ceux qui s'amusent à
faire
alors je dis donc un plat et qu'ils
aiment faire c'est à dire en plat qui
comporte beaucoup de choses alors qui
m'a toujours une assiette et qu'ils
mangent 10 à manger détention
voilà alors 3e d'abord 3e pour faire une
omelette déjà beau quand vous alors la
façon de casser les yeux et voyez où la
mettre le doigt dedans comme ça au kiné
super de rien ça on est obligé de faire
les hommes sont des gens et que ce n'est
pas l'argent des ménages eux nous
enchaînerons alors rapidement merci
parce que j'allais vous pouvez le jeter
on ne dira rien rien rien qui êtes si on
n'a pas la coquille et puis d'ailleurs
il faut que les chirurgiens doivent
aller aussi alors un peu de poivre et
spa vous n'étiez pas là pour me dire
arrêtez vous comment il faut faire pour
saler poivrer
quand on ne sait pas très bien faire à
convenir d'un seul coup on repère il ya
3 e donc il faut 3 pincées de poil de 16
ans tu es ma personne vous dire dans un
bruit de sel n'est ce pas sur chacun des
jeux et un peu de poids sur chacun des
jeux dans la rumba comme ceux ci
puissent pas croyez qu'ils sander alors
battre les oeufs ne pas battre le bol se
fait d'ailleurs figure d'ailleurs parmi
les autres recommandations
oui mais vous l'avez dit parce que vous
voyez que j'avais failli voilà les e
bonds alors ici un steak voilà promu le
sens à pognon alors ce boyau pour
l'escale open et envoyons de vaux sur
wii au louvre au milieu puis ensuite à
nouveau au milieu de façon enlever la
partie blanche qui est à l'intérieur et
aux un seul coup d'un seul anglaise où
cette graisse et envoyant de moutons
alors là il s'agit d'un demi oignon
alors je vais immédiatement pardon m
oh oui alors j'ai un trio une des
portables plein de ce bacille employés
d'une casserole
on s'est cru mettre à chauffer je vais
mettre un peu d'huile et un peu de
beurre dans chacune de ces deux
casseroles lui ne peut j'en pleurais
tout de suite et l'autre dans une petite
minute
voilà ici je n'ai pas pris car les
hommes aiment beaucoup les épices
donc j'ai pas pris car c'est fait pour
leur plaire leurs oignons
escaloper escale au csk et puis je m'en
vais mettre tout ça en série et je viens
d'y aller seul et avec leur église alors
les 6 es jolie de paprika d'une petite
couleur rose est désagréable et voilà
qui est fait c'est presque fini il n'y a
plus qu'à le maire ici au chaud c'est
nous allons mettre de l'huile dans les
mines et du beurre dans cette seconde
casseroles et elles auront besoin
le steak voilà nous allons le salé
d'abord car c'est extrêmement important
ne pas oublier qu'on doit sans lait la
viande au moment où on la met appui très
important très important pas avant n'est
ce pas ni après c'est au moment de la
mettrie on ne doit pas en principe la
cua vrai beaucoup on peut le faire si ça
plaît quand même bien le boire
le faire bon on met un petit peu plus
dessus comme ceci mais dans cette même
ville bien où on tourne et on retourne
le steak où qu'ils soient et ont le même
temps les grilles se régler au melaka
soirée bush et celle avec votre première
casserole vous n'est pas impossible que
vous enviez la première
alors dans cette seconde passion ou 2
vient de mettre du beurre à fondre avec
un tout petit peu d un v6 à tout ça
mijote un jeu merveilleux la cuisine
pour les quelques petites remarques
quand vous aurez fini
attention ne soyez pas méchant tout
jamais pensez vous être la physique
d'une prison du bonne humeur ça n'est
pas alors je vais ici tourner ce set
pour confirmer ce côté je continue à
faire cuire les oeufs brouillés et
brouillé à l'envoyer là quand c'est
assez chaud je retire la casse on ne
peut entrer les tient parce qu'il suffit
à la chaleur la 14 ce qui largement
maintenant qu'ils vont cuire suis romain
voilà voyez là c'est bien ça va comme ça
récit qui ça va être aussi qu alors je
voudrais ici encore une fois retourné ce
steak pour qu'ils soient quadrillés j'ai
volé bon et ce pour rappeler mon type
est un château guiraud je l'appelais
château guiraud parce que ce soit au
bureau c'est du vin blanc de chez moi et
j'aime beaucoup ce vin blanc alors
d'accord alors qu'il faudrait ajouter
voilà alors tout ça c'est prêt
voilà alors prêt facultative est
facultatif
on ne peut plus mettre dans un studio de
télévision alors une goutte d'alcool
là je ne sais pas mais secret voilà
votre bras gt c'est vrai j'ai pas pensé
à ma part j'ai pensé à mes sourcils
gestionnaire voilà j'avais c'est fini
alors maintenant nous prenons un plat
que voilà
et puis merci catherine landre quote je
suis avec vous c'est l'enfer
le stay tuned alors voyez vous les oeufs
on cuit donkey le mort et ils sont bien
moelleux je vais quand même y ajouter
une petite noisette de beurre minuscule
pour qu'il soit encore plus ambitieux
je m'en vais les versets comme ce site
valeo sur le sec
ils sont diront qu ils ont pris
simplement sur la période à 4 soit le
manque est tout bêtement comme ça dessus
à l'aide d'une cuillère vous laisse y
voyez faire une répartition titre ou le
lien s'inscrire
je vais mettre les rognons au milieu oui
je garde bien le juin c'est très
important parce que ce jus qui a été
fait avec un tout petit peu d'alcool
ville patrick a surtout qu'à cuit avec
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose de
sensationnel
alors voilà je vais faire un cordon
comme ceux ci tout autour est ce qu on
fait de l'art en plus c'est aller bien
sûr catherine
voilà ici
et puis je vais fermer bien alors
maintenant je vais vraiment pourquoi est
ce que pour faire ça tout ça vous avez
dit vous êtes est allé comme ça vous
avez deux cuisinières oui ça c'est pour
fait avoir il faut passer pas s'étonner
vient normalement je réussis avec une
cuisinière à gaz
une cuisinière électrique maintenant un
petit réchaud vous appelez bien ça un
piano oui ça s'appelle un piano et même
en cuisine nous avons l'habitude
d'appeler les fourneaux des pianos ce
qui fait que ça ne s'est pas du tout du
tout dépaysé et bien qu'athée je crois
que vous avez bien compris même si bien
compris mais je trouve que vous n'avez
fait aucune économie de matériel vous
voulez que j'économise en plus de
matières le regard des jeunes et ça dit
que ça j'ai fait les salit tout ça je
n'ai que ça c'est rien du tout
montrez-moi pouvais moi que vous pouvez
faire ça eh bien allons y capter je vais
vous le prouver tout de suite trouvé que
l'on veut se servir quoi finir de rien
se rendre là j'ai l'impression qu'ils
commencent déjà vraiment par changer de
costume vous allez bientôt être prêt oui
mais voilà quatre bons et bien si vous
voulez avoir la gentillesse empêché de
me passer les instruments il sait lire
nos amis terminé à 50 c'est pas ça qui
vous faut non je voudrais tout ce qu'est
ce que c'est tout ça voilà tout ça je
peux pas tout donnez moi la petite la
petite voiture
alors donnez moi les cas seront d'abord
alors voyez vous on a ici un tout prix
réchaud de rien du tout alors vraiment
de rien voilà un petit réchaud de rien
du tout sur lequel nous allons faire
chauffer la voix d'écart voyez où vous
allez avant la gentillesse de
m'approcher de me donner par exemple les
rognons qui sont coupés en morceaux
là vous avez gagné quand même un peu oui
il me faut un petit couteau
c'est à côté voilà alors je vais mettre
un peu de beurre dans chacune de ces
deux casseroles assez peu commun à
l'économie dans tous les domaines non
mais il a décrit comment c'est une
richesse c'est un petit réchaud à gaz
voilà alors jouer un peu d'huile et y en
a deux souhaits au dessous de vous dans
une assiette
voilà ma mise alors voilà il ya si peu
d'huile dans la première pas dans la
seconde je voudrais tout de suite les
rognons les bras et je vais attendre que
ce soit je voulais vous dans le paprika
le sel alors le paprika une police
exactement la même recette exactement
voilà je mélange comme j'ai fait tout à
l'heure
j'attends que ce soit chaud ça ne va pas
tarder et je voudrais encore l'huile le
sel encore voilà alors le sel est sale
et le steak n'est ce pas comme je lé
fais tout à l'heure alors pas du tout
alors lui louis mais vous mettez une
goutte d'huile mais d'ici là les faits
jamais rien
alors voilà je mets ici à griller jeu
mais vous voulez avoir la gentillesse de
me donner spatule en bois par exemple
voilà alors de remuer voyez-vous les
rognons tranquille puisque comme tout à
leurs biens commis tôt le steak est en
train de cuire parfaitement voilà la
chaleur de la casserole va suffire et
ici je vous demanderai un tout petit peu
de peur se voit la remettre à gérer ces
deux là c'est chaud chaud chaud très
chaud s'emporte ce genre de réchauds
comporte également tiré chaud vous
adresse et vous voilà
et puis à partir de maintenant je te
manque
voilà alors que ça cuit je m'en vais
mettre le steak sur le coin pour pouvoir
oui vous allez voir nous allons et
maintenant les yeux si vous voulez bien
les données je vous prie merci café
alors je n'allais pas un tout petit peu
ils ont été arraisonnés tout ça je n'ai
pas besoin de dix ans je rêvais régime
avait fait ouvrir très rapidement
puisque maintenant je crois que la
démonstration est faite on doit tourner
mais ça sera merveilleux aussi alors
naturellement on peut flamber ce n'est
pas utile que nous retombions nous
savons qu'il fallait le faire
ce n'est pas utile de recommencer cet
auteur a essayé de brûler ma base on va
la regarder
et voilà et bien c'est terminé 4es voilà
c'est bien je voudrais ajouter pour les
abords éteindre ça s'est très je
voudrais ajouter le plus petit modèle de
beurre mais alors minuscule dans les
colonies merci cadrée alors l'assiette
choc
le voilà sur laquelle nous allons mettre
le steak
vous avez quand même fait un minimum de
ben basât n'a pas du tout
voyez les oeufs brouillés ont cueilli
simplement sur la chaleur de la
casserole
nous allons les mettre comme nous avons
pu côtoyer des deux côtés un petit peu
sur deux têtes ils voient ça fait j'ai à
faire un repas entier vont pas manquer
sur une assiette non reliées au beau
milieu
il salue aussi sympathique que la barre
garde toujours le jus pour installer au
tour parfait et voilà
voyez qu'on peut aller comparer là vous
avez encore été maladroit c'est
maladroit c'est pour montrer qu'on paie
maladroit on peut à l'occasion est trop
maladroits on y va on y va
alors on va comparer pour voir si c'est
possible on l'a alors découvrez oui
voyez nous avons fait ça dans un temps
relativement très court en tout cas avec
le petit appareil la veille un petit
appareil minuscule sur le poteau par
conséquent voyez où la cuisine pour les
ondes doit aussi servir d'accueil de
camping c'est bien le genre de choses
que l'on peut faire un terrain de
camping c'est tout de même un plat
travailler c'est tout de même à plat
cuisiné regarder ça c'est mal à moi je
vais maintenant vous montrer ce que vous
devrez nous envoyer je vous ai dit tout
à l'heure vous parlerai du bon coup
imaginez que les missions d'aujourd'hui
a fait l'objet du concours
voilà ce que vous auriez dû faire vous
posons vous conseille de prendre un
cahier et dans ce cahier vous mettrez
les photos n'ont eu que vous aurez jugé
nécessaire de faire pour reconstituer la
recette en quelque sorte il ya des fois
où en deux photos vous aurait
reconstitué l'arcep d'autres fois il
vous aura fallu quatre cinq six j'en
sais rien il y a des fois il faudra deux
dessins quelquefois 4-5-6 j'en sais rien
non plus ça sera à vous de juger
alors là les photos sont très petit on
les a fait agrandir ça a été fait par un
amateur et on va vous faire voir ce que
ça a donné avec une légende
la légende elle est notée a fauté parce
que je meurs je pourrais pas la lire ici
voilà premières photos vous la voyez
bien je pense mon premier soin a été de
brouiller les oeufs le résultat ne s'est
pas fait attendre voyez alors plein
d'humour on vous a dit vous maintenant
vous encore une fois vous pouvez le
faire plus simplement vous voulez les
evènement pour une fois et des mois un
petit peu deuxième plan puis j'ai
habilement escaloper les rognons de
moutons cela s'est effectué sans à
convoyer lui a choisi le mouton bien vu
façon suivante je les ai fait flamber au
cognac ça il a oublié
je dois dire que j'ai particulièrement
soignée cette opération bravo nous
passons à la 4e une minute a suffi pour
faire griller le bifteck
ça suffit d'une minute oui vous jugerez
quand vous aurez à juger après il aimait
la viande très saignant mais elle y
entasser vous savez quand on est
délinquant on est incapable de trouver
un steak à points chez la femme dont le
mari aime le bifteck saignant elle le
fait toujours le bifteck au bout de son
mari pas chez nous j'ai alors dressé sur
un plat le bifteck que j'ai recouvert
avec les oeufs brouillés et sur leur lit
douillet j'ai couché les rognons il ne
me restait plus qu'à me mettre à table
ce que j'ai fait sans attendre voilà la
légende qui était prête mais ça ne
faisait pas défendu alors voilà voilà ce
que vous devrez faire si vous décidez de
participer à notre concours 1 1 si
quelque chose vous a échappé dans le
règlement de ce concours est bien
écrivez-nous 15 rue cognacq-jay la
cuisine pour les hommes de bien d'accord
si j'explose temps fait d'accord quand
un jour d'un par des campagnes et bien
écouté mais c'est terminé tout ça à lui
manque quelque chose
qu'est ce qui m'embête généraux a
peut-être de le goûter goûter la voix
mais ça n'avait on va dire d'un appétit
à raymond l'hiver pour une fois un c'est
bon il est modeste avec ça ils
apprécient ça c'est pas moi mais c'est
vrai que si cela tout le temps elle
avait touché au débat c'est la cuisine
pour les hommes c'est bien ce que je
disais et bien maintenant c'est le
générique qui nous montrent une fois
encore je ne croyais qu'ils sont chez
maxim's ries et son orchestre
c'était la cuisine pour les hommes une
émission de raymond olive est
représentée par catherine langeais avec
la participation de maxime saury et son
orchestre lumière de lycéens billard des
cordes yves ollivier réalisation pierre
mignot
[Musique]